fat jokes are kind of the great they're
clean they're a nice equalizer self
deprecating self-deprecating you kind of
get people on board I wanted to do
something a little different
structurally this time where I started
with a little bit more like I'm not a
big topical guy you know what I mean but
I started with a little more like you
know just kind of [__] on the you
know [__] on Austin which then got
into Tech stuff and kind of [__] on
a couple things and then I did a long
story in the front of the special which
I always used to think like structurally
should go at the end and then I got the
fat jok in the middle and I close on
Dick jokes like for me my entire career
has been like uh